So Carl, one thing I wanted to ask
you was, if I'm a solo entrepreneur,
how would I go about finding an engineer
to help me work on these projects?
>> Finding an engineer can come
in a myriad of different ways.
You can always place an ad on
something like Craigslist.
There's the tried and true LinkedIn, or
even a site like Stack Overflow does
a really good job of
representing developers.
Of course,
if you're a hackathon attendee,
maybe you'll be assigned a team mate.
So, that might be just
a serendipitous meeting.
Of course, you can always go
rummaging around in cafes or
coffee shops and looking for
people with laptops as well.
>> Okay.
And how would I go about choosing
an engineer if I had two, three people
answer my Craigslist ad, how would I go
about choosing who I want to work with?
>> Choosing who you work with is,
something I think that's dependant
on what your end goal is.
If you're looking for,
maybe a web-based project, then you
want to focus on the specific skill set.
So you're looking for somebody with
a background in HTML/CSS and JavaScript.
If you're looking to go full-fledged
mobile, maybe native experience.
Then you're looking for
somebody with iOS development experience
with Objective C or Swift, or even in
branching out into Android as well,
you will need somebody who has,
experience with that SDK and with Java.
>> How would I go about
working with an engineer?
When I've found one that
I want to work with,
how do I go about actually
asking them for help?
How do I go about
getting use out of them.
>> Sure.
>From my perspective,
I like to get involved as earlier
in the project life cycle as I can.
Getting me involved means, showing me a
lot of the design work that's happening.
Explaining a lot of your thinking.
As your feature set is evolving
through the design process.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I am going to want to understand
what you're end goals are.
I'm going to want to understand what you
believe is the minimum viable product.
And I'm going to want to understand
what your longer term goals are for
your project.
>> Right, and so naturally, you would
want to be involved as early as possible
and that would be the way to get
the most use out of you, but
there's also this pull of,
if I'm the sole entrepreneur,
I might have a limited budget.
I might not be able to pay you for
the entire life of the project.
>> Yeah.
>> So in that case,
would it make more sense to just take
you on at the end when I can actually,
just ask you to build the app and
that's all I've got money for?
>> Well, the app experience can be as
big or as small as you want to make it.
So bringing me on at
the end would be okay, but
I think we lose a lot of the context.
A lot of the decisions that are made
through the prototyping phase,
through the design phases, I think can
inform upon how the product is built.
So again.
And
I would want to come on a little bit
earlier in the product life cycle.
Now that said,
if you do leave it towards the end,
then you're going to want to
have a really well-defined spec,
a really fleshed out idea
of what you want build.
And then you're going to want to
be able to talk to that engineer
about the budget.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You're going to want to talk about
the feature set that you're asking them
to build, and
then you're also going to want to to
set some realistic delivery dates.
>> Right.
And of course, one common thing is
if I'm an entrepreneur who doesn't
have a background in coding,
then what's going to happen is,
I might set these unrealistically.
It might not occur to me
that thing X is going to
take a lot longer to build than thing Y.
I might assume that they're going to
take the same amount of time and
set, give you these
delivery dates that are for
this one, totally doable and
this one, way unrealistic.
>> Yep, and that's why I like to get
engaged to a project early on, so
that I can set some realistic
expectations as well.
I do think that it's important to
involve your developers in that regards,
so that we don't end up with
something like feature creep or
scope creep within the project.
It's very easy to become quite enamored
with a particular interaction or
a set of screens, that maybe are not
core integral to the experience.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But we believe in launching and
iterating.
So, striving towards that, I mean,
viability, and then involving
the developer early on will
help you establish what that looks like,
and help you craft a plan of execution.
>> Perfect, thank you very much.
>> You're welcome.